engineering at hebrew university of
jerusalem
giant in the field of algorithms also
combinatorics applications of geometry
and analysis to those areas
an isi highly cited
researcher i'm very happy to have ngati
telling us about graphs as geometric
objects welcome marty
thank you
[Music]
okay so i think by now with all the
previous talks that we we heard
perhaps the the first few slides are
completely redundant
we already heard about how to
investigate
important algorithmic questions such as
flows and networks we also heard how
the
brains of elements are
[Music]
when they navigate is
modeled after a taurus
etc
but i hope to convince you that there is
still huge territories
uh in in the interaction between drafts
and geometry
that we still understand too little
about
so just to to be on the same page
these are my my basic premises that
everything fundamental that you know in
geometry has an interesting
combinatorial counterpart
and again just to have the language
correct
geodesic geometry or geodetic geometry
is for example what you do in romanian
surfaces when
you determine how to go from one point
to the other there is a genetic path
that connects them
uh
okay so that we already said and let me
actually it was quite a surprise for me
to discover
this old mansion i don't know how many
people are familiar with the name of
austin ore
but he he wrote one of the
he was a danish mathematician both both
in graph theory and group theory
very influential
and in a one of the first books modern
books in graph theory
he introduced the notion of a
geodetic graph he calls the graph
geodetic if
between any two vertices in the graph
there is a unique shortest path
so some examples
a
trees
complete graphs old cycles and perhaps
one more interesting one is
peterson's graph which you see here
and why does peterson graph have this
property
he will this this graph will reappear
later on in a different context or
somewhat related context this is the
graph with the diameter diameter two and
in girth five which means
every two vertices are either connected
by an edge or
by a unique path of length two so in
particular that's a genetic graph and he
he raised the question of
can we characterize these graphs and the
the it is still very far from from being
solved
so to simplify matters or to concentrate
or thought about this i only want to
restrict myself to graphs
in which first of all to connect it
that's quite obvious that
any cut point really trivializes the
question and so i want to assume to
connect it and i also want to assume
that all the vertices of degree at least
three and that makes the problem more
combinatorial and more geometric
and so i want to formulate a conjecture
that is such a graph so geodetic
two connected all vertex degree
or at least three
there is an absolute top around on the
diameter of such graphs the construction
that we know at the moment for this is
hezbollah five perhaps that's that's the
most
so you see such very simple notions
already very very old questions and we
know very little about them
so there is of course we actually saw
them even today
there is of course a very strong
connection between graphs and metric
spaces
if you give me any connected graph and
you put
positive weights on the edges then that
determines a distance between any two
vertices the the sum of
the length of of the edges in a shortest
path
and just to simplify matters i'm
completely going to ignore
tie breaking because for example if i
choose the edge length at random that
will happen with probability zero so no
mention of tie breaking at all
but even this which is really so so
simple very soon will lead us to very
simple questions that we still don't
know the answer from
uh so
a path system i mean a weight system on
the edges
induces a path system on the graph
it's a consistent path system so between
any
two vertices i have a chosen path and
consistency means that if the path the
chosen path from u to v goes
by x and y then the sub path between x
and y
is the chosen a path
between x and y so this is a consistent
path system this is the main thing about
which we're going to be talking today
uh
okay so
already here are some some questions
that we still don't know the the answer
for
uh
so suppose i give you two different
weight systems on the edges
i want to consider them equivalent if
they determine the same path system
and even the following very simple
questions we don't know the answer to
i give you a graph how many distinct
equivalence classes are there
uh how small can this number be this i
think we know the answer to but hey when
going through that how large it can it
be there we have a conjecture but still
it's not known so even these very simple
things which you can explain to students
in the more second class in a class of
algorithm or graph theory
they remain open
so this is the the first question that
my student daniel sisma with whom we did
this work asked ourselves
does every consistent path system come
from a collection of edge lengths
and i call a graph for which the answer
is yes metrizable and otherwise
non-metallizable so
we're asking are all two connected
graphs symmetrizable turns out the
answer is no
and let's start with an example so you
already remember
the computer itself and you remember i
told you that every two vertices are
either adjacent or are connected by a
unique path of length two so my path
system my consistent path system is
mostly going to use the obvious thing if
they're
adjacent then i use the edge if they're
distance two mostly i i
connect them by the path of links too
and there are five exceptions five
exceptional pairs you see for example
the the red path that goes from two to
one to to six to eight
and and all other uh the green one and
so on and so forth
these although they can be connected by
two hop
i i chose this freehold connection
between them
it's very easy to verify
that this is a consistent path system
and now i want to show you that this
path system doesn't consistent path
system doesn't come from any system of
length on the edges why
so suppose they were so suppose i
associate a positive number w i j to
every edge i j in the graph
and then i can write some inequalities
right the first inequality that you see
here
says that
in order to go from two to eight the
three hope path that they chose is no
longer than the obvious two hope
path and you write all these inequality
you sum them up and you conclude
that all the edges in the middle of this
picture
have non-positive weights which is of
course a contradiction so we prove
that the peterson graph is non-metrical
non-metrizable and we actually found a
consistent path system that doesn't that
is non-metric
so what do we know so i i don't have
time to really tell you today
too many technical things perhaps i'll
show you one small proof just for taste
but these are the main discoveries that
daniel and i have have made
so metrizability is there and i'll make
this more concrete later so but in any
sense of the word
almost all graphs are magnetizable
yet there are infinitely many a
non-trivial two connected
methodizable graphs every outer planar
graph is retraceable and if you don't
remember the definition i'll tell you
later on
and
something that really
surprised me quite a bit
i give you a graph and i ask you is it
metrizable or not
this can be answered in in polynomial
time
but i must say that
one lesson that this investigation
taught me is uh
which supposedly we know this very well
but it's quite striking when you see
this so clearly there is a big
difference between solvable and
polynomial time and something that we
really understand
so
equivalent we saw we spoke about
consistent path system
there is something equivalent to it
which is a consistent tree system
so this is a collection of spanning tree
you can think of there is one rooted at
every vertex
and consistency means that in the tree
the uv path in the tree
root of the two and the three rooted at
v are identical and the two notions are
equivalent that's very easy to show
for a path system you move to a tree by
simply collect collecting all the path
that go to the root and this creates a
tree
and it's also very easy to grow from
from
three systems to two path systems so
the two notions are equivalent
so let me give you
so you can
the the subject is really very very rich
i mean i i only give you a the first
taste of it and and there are lots of
lots of
very basic things that
we would like to know and we we still do
not know
but just for for a sense you you can
speak also about
a
partial path systems that are consistent
but
if you look at this uh
diagram that we have here
you you can easily convince yourself
that although this partial one is
consistent it cannot be extended to a
consistent path full a
path system that is consistent
but
moving from a subgraph to the whole
graph that can be done
so very basic things that we still learn
mr so so just again to remind to to
recap
so
i give you a graph i give you a path
system
a
i call the paths it's a consistent path
system i call it retriesable if it can
be realized by
edge weights
and the
strictly metricizable if the inequality
is so strict
and according to that i call the graph
geometrizable or strictly retracement
and
so one nonatrial non-metric path
consistent path system already makes the
graph normally traceable that's just to
i'm just recapping the
repeating the the basic definitions
and and metrisability is determined by
the two connected components of the
graph so in fact it's enough to consider
two connected graphs in this discussion
so i want to very briefly so you know
there is a
mathematical talk without without the
proof
is considered missing so i'll i i'm not
going to
prove to you but just quickly sketch to
you
just a tiny part of the bigger theorem
that that
i mentioned already so so
an outer planar graph is is a graph
which you can draw in the plane
in such a way that all the vertices
reside
on the outer boundary
and the simplest such graphs is the
cycle so all these graphs
are metrizable and let me briefly
describe to you how we prove
that cycles are aromatizable so let let
me
again repeat
if i give you a path it's a consistent
path system on a cycle
then there are an edge length that that
will give you that
it comes from some collection of edgelit
so it belongs to to the exception and
not the rule
so let's try to understand how this goes
so
really uh what does a
so here we're using this notion of of a
consistent tree system so a tree a sub
tree of
of the cycle is simply remove an edge
so
in order to describe the consistent
power system on a tree system on on the
cycle
every vertex should tell which edge it
removes in order to choose or to do to
determine it's
a tree in the
consistent tree system
so you can think about the whole thing
as a mapping for vertices to edges so
like here the blue vertex
chooses the blue edge which means the
the tree
grouted at the blue vertex is the cycle
minus
the blue edge
and the the first step that you prove is
that for a
such a function
to correspond to a consistent path
system it has to be crossing as you see
here
the
pink and the blue
edge cross each other and every two such
things should cross each other and if
and only for
such a system to be consistent
and then what you prove
is that you can shrink or contract
edges in the graph and still in the
cycle and still
maintain a consistent path system or
consistent tree system and then
eventually
if you have something like in the
picture on the left the two you see
there are two yellow vertices that both
choose this this yellow edge
across
then you can shrink
the the the white edge the edge that
contains them and the theorem says that
if you do this if you have a consistent
tree system on this cycle
and you shrink all these
white edges like here
and eventually you end up with an odd
cycle and they started a
metric on on the old cycle and that's
essentially
the proof that that cycles
are armaturizable
okay
so
let's talk about uh this uh family of
fertilizable grass
and
as it turns out
metrisable graphs are closed undertaking
topological mining so let me go over
this statement and make sure that we all
understand what that means
so i say that
if if the graph g contains a subgraph
which is an isomorphic to a subdivision
of h then we say that h is a topological
minor of t
so let me repeat the sentence it's a
little bit of a mouthful so let me say
this again the class of metrizable
graphs is closed under taking
topological minors
stated differently if a graph as a
topology has a subdivis contains the
subgraph that's a subdivision of
anonymizable graph that makes the big
graph also nonetheless so this gives me
a way of proving that certain graphs are
normally transmitted
the obvious thing for anyone who who
knows about
the the important development in in in
modern graph theory the obvious question
to ask is is it a minor closed family
that's something we know much more about
the thanks to the fantastic theory of
robertson and simmer but the answer is
no no this is not a minor closed family
this is an example the graph on the left
is metrisable but if you shrink the top
edge
then you get the the graph on the right
which is normalizable so it is not a
minor closed family
uh
so let me say something about about the
the proof of our main theorem or one of
our main theorems
uh
i already said i haven't been specific
about this but i will in in two minutes
that essentially a vast majority of all
graphs are monometrizable how how did we
prove it
um
i don't think this would
win a beauty contest but it's still a
quite quite a lot of work involved in
this so we found these 10
graphs that that appear here we found
them using the computer and we
found
a
for each one of them a consistent path
system that's non-metrical how did you
prove that it's non-metrical in the same
way that we proved it for for the
peterson without the inequalities and we
got a contradiction just using linear
programming
and now using the fact that that
methodizable graphs are closed
under taking a topological manner we use
these as building blocks so let me i
just want to stress this point which is
rather i think interesting especially
for computer scientists
a i don't know that we would be able to
to
prove these things by hand perhaps yes
but i doubt it
so while all these 10 graphs were found
by a computer
and they were
you know essential building blocks for
for the proofs the fact that they are
non-metrisable is very easily verifiable
by humans so if you want uh you know
bring home the the notion of p versus np
uh it's very easy to verify very easy
for a human to verify
quite not so easy to to find
by humans
so
so essentially we have two
main ways to prove number twice ability
either to construct an explicit path
system like the
let's say consistent and and
non-realizable like we we did with the
with the peterson graph or finding g a
subdivision of a non-networkable graph
from this collection that we
call the the zoo and in fact uh i won't
elaborate on this but
this allows you to to give a different
proof for the non-metrizability of the
periods in graph
so now i can
be more specific
about what i mean
that essentially almost all graphs are
normalizable
so you can read the theorem but let me
skip it and and and come to to the
conclusions which are you know easier to
to swallow so every three connected
graph with at least eight vertices it
normally tries every two connected
non-planar graph with at least eight
vertices in dominant threshold every two
connected graph with the reality at
least three at least thirteen vertices
is normal transmission so if we have any
sense of of what any notion of random
graphs
look like then you realize that
it's not so easy while there exists uh
methodizable graphs that are quite real
a
so
okay so let me explain now
that we do know i i told you that cycles
are metrizable but actually this is a
special case of a more general theorem
which says
that every outer planar graph is
strictly maturizable outer planar means
again that it can be drawn in the plane
in such a way
that all the vertices are on the outer
boundary and here you see a few examples
so so the
quick proof that i sketched for you
about about the cycles it can be
considered
you know as a small exercise
towards the proof of this it's quite a
complicated move
okay
so
how come how come we are able i also
mentioned as as a third
thing that we discovered we we i said
that we can decide whether a
graph a given graph is metrisable or not
so
while it is
so we have a method
i which we already saw using linear
programming so
it's relatively
i mean we have we have all the way we
still need to know
a few tricks of the trade in in linear
programming to do this but
they're quite standard for for people
who who do this so using this linear
programming approach that gives you a
proof that humans can verify that a
given graph is is normalizable but
although as i said we can decide it in
polynomial time
uh
the proofs of of metrisability are still
mysterious to us so what happens here
uh
if since since this class is closed
under topological miners there is always
a list
of uh
of of the minimal objects which don't
follow the clusters they are
non-naturalizable but
if you a any proper topological minor of
them
is metrizable so we want to understand
what this is so so just to illustrate so
you're with me on this so i think you
all know or most of you know
the classical theorem of kratovsky which
characterizes planarity the graph is
planar if and only if it doesn't contain
either k5 or neither k5 or k3 is
topological miners
and the
the great theorem of robertson and
zimmer one of the greatest
accomplishments of of modern
combinatorics
says that every
minor closed family
is characterized by a finite least of
forbidden graphs the only the only
surprising word in this theorem is the
finite question there is such a list
is nothing but the the fact that it's
finite that's the the big achievement
here it's a it's a huge theorem
but the analogous theorem is is not true
for for topological manuals so here we
have a family
of infinite family of
graphs which shows that the analogous
thing for topological miners it doesn't
hold and yet there is enough stretch to
don't have time to elaborate on this
which allows us to to conclude
that the list
of of minimal counter examples so to
speak is finite and this in principle
says
that we have a polynomial time algorithm
to to decide metrizability but this is
very very far
from being an actual algorithm that we
can run and and and use so
there is still a lot of of mystery to to
unveil here which we don't understand
so
concretely i want to ask can we find the
full list of topologically minimal
non-neutralizable graphs
that would be we know that it's a finite
least but i have no idea you know if
it's a hundred graphs or a hundred to
the hundred to the hundred no no idea
and and the thing that i i mentioned
before
so can we find
a
proof certificates for metris ability
that humans can can understand this is
still at the moment
open
so let me just say a little word about
about
these approaches with linear programming
you you have such
systems of inequalities like we we saw
before
and
on the face of it it's it's problematic
because
these systems are exponentially large
but using ellipsoids and and this kind
of things
these systems can be solved so
normalizability
can be can be done efficiently i mean in
a way that we understand
but materializability is is still a
mystery and with this else talk thank
you very much
[Applause]
thanks notty questions
oh if not
we'll move on to our next speaker let's
thank nutty again